the cleaners and outcasts are very
similar groups in terms of their origin
structure weapons and technology tactics
and fighting style
they each utilise an arsenal of homemade
weapons and mercilessly kill
anyone and everyone who was against them
and both were born through tragedy their
leaders faced after the death of loved
ones
but what would happen if they were put
it up against each other and who would
come out on top
[Music]
not long after the green poison found
its way into washington dc
the jtf set up a quarantine on roosevelt
island
the sick were brought here to give them
a greater chance of receiving the
medical treatment they needed
but also to assist in stopping the
spread of the virus
they were completely reliant on
personnel on the outside of the gates
and so they trusted and believed that
everything they needed would be provided
however they also had no comprehension
or awareness of what was happening off
the island
and the jtf officer in charge of
quarantine and watching over the people
on the island
was a colonel by the name of antoine
ridgeway
now ridgeway could see what was
happening on both sides as he witnessed
firsthand
the sick get sicker and their numbers
increasing
and outside of roosevelt island he
observed security forces quickly losing
control of washington dc
a new society was on the brink of
collapse
as resources going to roosevelt island
started to decline
ridgeway decided enough was enough the
government was losing control of the
city
the sick were obviously a lost cause and
everyone's priorities
needed to change drastically so ridgway
ordered to cease all supplies from
entering the quarantine zone
no more food water or medicine was to be
administered
he was leaving them to starve to death
and so unsurprisingly
over time these people starving and
running out of options
decided to come together and work out a
solution on how to overthrow their
captives
and escape the island they began to
notice a reduction in guard activity
and decided it was the time to act upon
it
rallying a number of people from within
the quarantine community an individual
named emmeline shaw successfully managed
to generate an uprising
capable of overthrowing their captors
and they called themselves
the outcasts abandoned by the people
who'd sworn to protect them
and rallied by the brilliant
persuasiveness of the new leader shaw
these survivors became united in their
quest for survival and bent on revenge
against those who had wronged them
as their numbers grew so did their
influence over others
and in time they were able to convince
many others to take up arms and join
their cause
with everyone feeling empowered and
finally free of the shackles put in
place by the government
shaw increased her messages on the
current situation they were all in
how they were on their own how the
government left them to die
and how everyone else in society just
sat back and let it happen
any one of those people could have made
a stand and fought for them
but they didn't and therefore they're
just as guilty as the government
it was also around this time that shaw
found out that she is a rare
asymptomatic carrier of the virus
and while she doesn't suffer from the
side effects of the virus she still
carries it within her body
and it can be easily transmitted to
others
this news only further enhanced the
cult-like behavior of the group that was
starting to form around her
but more importantly to them it provided
the outcasts with a new weapon
they could use in their mission to
create havoc in washington dc
their goal to spread the dollar flew
throughout the healthy citizens of the
city
the cleaners originated as the
blue-collar workers of new york city
janitors sanitation garbagemen
electrician
construction workers truck drivers these
were the people that the government
initially asked to assist them in saving
the city
through transport digging of mass graves
and eventually the construction of the
wall that would surround the quarantine
zone
these were the groups that continued to
support the civil services
even when the city infrastructure was
breaking down
unfortunately these are also some of the
people that were left behind
when the jtf and government pulled out
of the dark zone
and much like the first wave of division
agents these men were left feeling
betrayed
and abandoned it was at this point that
an individual by the name of joe ferro
stepped up and organized these abandoned
workers into a force
that would do anything that was needed
to contain the virus and restore order
to the streets of new york city
pharaoh's wife was one of the first
victims to become infected and shortly
after succumbed to the virus
with his wife dead he continued to think
that the government wasn't doing
anything to really stop
the virus and he believed that no one
had stepped up and was brave enough to
do anything about it
with all of his faith in the government
lost he decided to take matters into his
own hands
so he assembled the people who had
worked alongside the jtf and the
government before they left
he proceeded to tell them that there was
now only one way to stop the virus
burn it burn all of it burn every trace
of it
and thus the cleaners were born
they believe that they are the true
heroes fighting against the virus in the
front lines
they're the ones leaving everything they
had behind just so they could stay in
new york
and do what has to be done the cleaners
are devoted to their job
and if anyone gets in the way they're a
part of the problem and is swiftly dealt
to
comprised mostly of untrained civilians
over time they have managed to organize
themselves
into a force that could almost resemble
an army
both the outcasts and the cleaners have
a number of roles within their ranks
from the assault rushers throwers and
snipers
all the way through to the support
engineers and heavies these two factions
are structured in a very similar way
with only very minor differences between
the classes
during combat outcasts usually behave
more recklessly than other factions in
the division
choosing to focus heavily on close
combat and foregoing the safety of cover
although they have a sniper role within
their ranks they are few and far between
instead relying on the crude technical
explosive and fire abilities during
combat
while they are more suited to hunting
and killing unarmed civilians
they have learned to be more than
capable against armed dangerous foes
their support types can turn the tide of
battle because of the fire rounds they
can provide
but the tanks and scorches support the
bulk of their strategy
which in general is to pin the targets
down with suppressive gunfire while the
close combat specialists move into
position
the cleaners are skilled in guerrilla
warfare and are particularly good with
utilizing whatever they find to build
weapons
and technology their tactics are
aggressive and focus on coordinated
offensives
while the assaults and rushes are found
on the front lines constantly keeping
the enemy off balance
and unable to establish a solid position
the engineers
controllers and tanks are found closely
behind at medium range
keeping them locked down and unable to
regroup
the assault class will usually pin
targets down while another rushes up to
them to set them alight from behind
the thrower rolls job is very similar
any target choosing to take cover
will quickly be pinned down using flame
and gas grenades
while rushers and flamers move up to
finish the job
much like the outcasts the cleaners are
less of a concern at range
they have snipers but due to the lack of
training throughout their forces
their numbers are low however the more
recent addition of the napalm turret
should not be underestimated their range
is long and can quickly overwhelm
if left unchecked
both factions were established due to
the chaos that unfolded following the
dollar flu outbreak
predominantly consisting of civilian
personnel with little to no military
experience or training
they more than make up for this with
numbers and a strong passion to do what
they believe is right
one through revenge and one through the
necessity to fill a gap
that they believe is lacking from
official agencies
although lacking an experience their
time over the many months since the
outbreak
has seen them each develop tactics and
strategy that even the most disciplined
force would struggle to counter
[Music]
both factions can be seen wielding
various types of assault rifles
lmgs marksman rifles smgs and shotguns
however most of these have been acquired
from foes they have taken down
and they have no real experience in
training behind them
the bulk of their weapons are homemade
from the kim launchers
and flamethrowers to the remote control
cars with saw blades attached
and drones that drop firebombs
regarding their technology these two
groups are quite evenly matched
the only real difference between them is
the outcast use of the virus
itself while the cleaners wish to
destroy it
the outcasts would only like to see it
spread
the cleaners and outcasts are very
similar in their origins
structure technology weapons tactics and
fighting style
both utilise homemade weapons and
mercilessly kill anyone and everyone who
was against them
and both were brought to be through
leaders after the death of their loved
ones
the cleaners were assembled in an
attempt to save the city unfortunately
the misguided methods had them set on a
more brutal genocidal path
the outcast came to be through an
individual who was stricken by grief
who also happen to be charismatic and
able to work on people's vulnerabilities
in order to have them follow her beliefs
however their goals are very different
while the cleaners seek to eradicate the
virus through fire
the outcasts instead seek to spread the
virus and kill those who allowed them to
suffer
the outcasts as their name suggests see
themselves as having been cast aside by
society
and in turn have reacted through
becoming brutal merciless murderers who
prey on the innocent who are simply
trying to survive
both have learned to fight in a manner
that overcomes their lack of tactical
training
by providing constant offensive pressure
never allowing the opposing force to be
able to gain traction
or gather their bearings if those who
come up against them are able to resist
the initial rush
things will quickly go downhill for each
of the factions
their numbers are similar both from
their initial uprisings
and the number of sympathisers have
joined their ranks since
so i believe that in a situation where
both of these groups were to come up
against each other
that they would almost be in a stalemate
almost
while they each fight for a cause that
they believe is well deserved
one in particular stands out and could
easily drive the fight in their favor
although a single battle would likely
see no obvious winner the long-term goal
of one
is likely to come out on top as much as
this pains me
to say due to the other faction being my
favorite within the division universe
i see the outcasts as having the edge in
this fight
they may be matched in weaponry training
and numbers and they also each have the
unwavering drive to complete what has
been put in front of them
but the outcasts have a little something
extra crazy
and we all know you don't mess with
crazy
the outcasts have grown into a somewhat
cult-type group all based on the
ramblings of the charismatic
leader emeline shaw and although she has
finally been brought down by the
division
this has only made her following fight
that much harder for the legacy she's
left behind
and while the cleaners are well aware of
what they're putting themselves into
the outcasts are willing to go that much
further to achieve their goals
death isn't a problem to them it's
almost a goal
a way to show how devoted they are
this psychological aspect alone is
likely to tip the tide of the cleaner
outcast battle
they are simply willing to go further
and more out there to get on top
what the cleaners are likely to see as
being too far probably doesn't even
register on the outcast moral compass
while they have all lost loved ones and
decided to take it upon themselves to
make things right
the outcasts have lost a little more of
themselves to this conflict and are
willing to do that much more to serve
the new family
regardless of how much of the humanity
they have to leave behind
[Music]
following on from the last verses video
this seemed to be a bit of interest
and i've kind of wanted to make some of
these on the factions for quite some
time now
but i never got around to it so
hopefully you enjoyed this otherwise
thank you very much for watching and
i'll catch you in the next one
[Music]
[Applause]
cheers
[Music]
foreign